okay okay okay okay hey this is way into
until everyone knows oh my gosh oh I
can't believe this sorry I'm just I'm
just um making a suite and stuff I
should have done this before
I'm just not thinking I'm all second
gonna act in some people's did any of
you guys come from Instagram I let you
just find out just now and I made like I
was them I just went live on Instagram
when I was like oh okay I'm gonna I'm
gonna do a live reaction on YouTube yeah
so crazy this is just so crazy I just
kind of believe it oh I think in the
tweet I forgot to put a link today oh my
gosh I can't I can't even think right
now I'm just like yeah yeah it's got
stupid it never updates quick enough
it's got the stupid other title but the
title of this video it says it's saved
but it hasn't and it always does this
it's live reaction to market fire
playing my game cuz he frickin played
perfection and I'm like what oh it's
just like oh okay wait yes I mean get my
thoughts in order here before is that
going out city crazy so I'm recording
this as well just in case I made this
like
a reaction video oh this is just it's
just too crazy let me just quickly share
this to ya X page on Facebook so
everyone knows I want everyone to see
this what yeah whatever
sure now okay sweet nice perfect
beautiful okay who have you got here
hello everyone thank you for coming
great work thank you very much
Pat hey hon hey hon thank you thank you
thank you I really appreciate that yeah
so this is absolutely crazy this is like
absolutely crazy this is crazy freakin
crazy sir what just happened is I was
eating my dinner and you know stuffing
my face with some veggies and some hot
sauce and then I get snapchat from one
of my close friends who I actually was
living with at the time of developing
this game and she's so because there's
so many breakdowns because of it and
she's just like it's just a video of
Makkah fire and she's like yes men yes
men and I'm like I mean it was just
crazy to me that anyone was playing the
game and duh so if you came from his
video then please let me know
I actually I need to write on his video
so I've read it I've read it on the net
ready I can't speak I write on it now
while I'm okay so let
just do this you guys couldn't have a
little have a look-see
you guys can see so I've got it up here
and let's move it let's move this
actually yeah
let's move it here so you can see
everything nice nice nice nice ah okay
starting to calm down a little bit I was
very overwhelmed for a very long time
and I'm pretty overwhelmed so let's just
quickly I just let's watch it and then
I'll reply in a comment okay so I just
can't believe this I can't believe this
hello here of time hello Ellen ah hey
women's favorites is also my housemates
so he saw me go through various
breakdowns dude like through the
development of this game but look at
this this is all worth it's all worth it
that explains the girl hey yeah I'm the
girl the beginning the video I made that
video as well because I do YouTube too
but yeah Michael got notified by YouTube
Thank You YouTube for notifying people I
appreciate that
and Leon Tay Leon say is that how you
see your name you came from Mike's video
thank you for being curious and checking
me out I really appreciate that you can
thank the first comment on his video the
first comment on his video what that
girl was hella cute I'm not cute
such a trigger word I am badass but
thank you anyway
[Music]
does anyone say like yeah it's yak my
legs
she's a thoughts no I'm not
yak my neck she's a youtuber you guys
check it out thanks max I don't know if
you're here but thank you max appreciate
you and Shanshan yeah yeah yeah I
appreciate this okay so let's let's play
let's actually watch and play
and get overwhelmed
hey tabs here tells us a character
artist Tabitha
look who played our game just saying
look who played our game okay let's
listen watch the video dick my name is
markiplier and welcome to profession one
sec getting crazy going crazy actually I
was talking about my cuteness um earlier
today I was saying that I should really
have been like a delinquent Oh like I
dig like a left like a you know serial
killer or something cuz no one would
know no one would think it was me anyway
let's carry on hello everybody my name
is markiplier and welcome to perfection
no not me not my beautiful face some
people think that I do you mean that
it's me who's perfection and it's not
okay I made a video
oh my god that one that one I I want
that one make you know we can overlay
[Music]
so you can finally realize your true
potential
[Music]
do you like my editing skills mark okay
free market imperfection Isaac real my
perfect my skin perfect oh my eyes
perfect okay yeah sorry it's a really
long an amazing shirt nice I'm glad you
like the environment design
I'll let be environment to learn in
there okay whoa it's a really bad
computer also I like how I kind of slink
inside yeah the III animated that step
by step at him it looks more like you've
got you gotta choose your gender module
which image makes you feel the most
uneasy
I mean well that guy can see me but I
can see him too and that's just like
finger and I the broken mirror that
probably suggests something more they
all need a perfection okay well what are
you doing with it what are you doing
with it
Oh oh my god I am already perfect I know
I'm already perfect you don't need to
change much do you like my music let me
get a good another good look at me
that's me singing me that I I have to
say goodbye to this yeah he bidding
beacon of a man
[Music]
Browdy holy [ __ ] look at my hands he's
so cute like one heaping helping of
perfect please
Oh ever symptoms of imperfection my
flaws that I always know that I have
important things for me and everyone
else and I tried hard to do it but I
never do and I consequence i disappoint
people I'd love to be perfect I would
change my attribute of laziness to
productivity I would never let down my
friends and family again okay all right
good all right perfect music oh yeah
sound design these are my friends and
the pictures you're gonna peek marked
coach you're gonna peek cord of course
you're gonna peek much this is so
different I'm so used to hearing this
music while developing and being
stressed it will not be you when you can
be perfect that's what I've been my
whole life
that's what I've been saying good we
just need to be perfect wait hang on
there movies in that door that said it
wasn't in use what was in that door yeah
I gotta go back absolutely nothing music
[Music]
oh yeah so there's only one if you
choose one of the pictures all the
paintings change and that one with the
glitz you won't trust 7231 but then it's
my fault because I should have really
good
procrastination depression anxiety to
get talents to have more
kinesthetic awareness for status respect
money friends love to be more competent
to unlock yeah these are real by the way
I asked people with their flaws on
Twitter and this is me like replying to
them or what if your how do I do that
do I just smash it on my noggin I've got
a real big head I don't know
okay he's Alaska his name is Terra
it's like ambiguous gender oh maybe I
shouldn't have put that thing on my head
okay yes there is glad you see that some
seems different camp on my finger upon
it come on keep going keep going okay he
found the pregnancy chest someone
pregnant maybe probably not considering
wait a minute my nose in my mouth my
nose in my mouth you peeped therefore
you get peeps I know you're wearing the
headset Oh
why were you watching me hey that's a
trick question why do you think I was
watching you you were watching me
okay whose blood is this I hope he
checks out the images actually sitting
in a perfectly normal place for blood
oh hi wait wait oh no it's so
embarrassing no oh oh this is so
embarrassing so embarrassing you just
keep going just keep going so fast right
now
oh my field of view just got really
invigorated yes this is a special camera
technique that it took forever for me to
code so enjoy I'm here for my perfection
therapy you've already had it
thank you for caring
[Music]
you getting PT vibes
oh it's darker that's always a good sign
Oh something's different can I place my
finger upon it oh no you may be better
thank you
oh because he chose the mirrors
therefore is supposed to represent that
he's scared about like appearance
appearance in appearing ugly yes that's
not right
can I look at you again can I stare
deeply longingly yeah the window or the
soul what does that mean when it's on a
door your eyes the door to my heart or
whatever how are you doing all right
cool okay just hide me are you looking
good so if you chose the I the eyes I
like clothes and Oprah and you choose
the person sitting on their own the
people literally walk out of the frame
to leave you on your own
oh hi hello how are you doing is this
another pregnancy test
yeah did you left here I don't know you
know I don't know man there's a floating
blood [ __ ] he didn't know this okay good
okay profession is necessary mmm gas is
used disgusting gross this is being more
observant now I like it
I guess I don't need to look at those
why
hey listen buddy look at how good yeah
okay that's fine
I'm not too worried about that
go on then turn around then yah woof oh
oh okay hey we just swing wildly right
here in the air affect me would have won
if he's gonna find the Easter egg shaped
dead I'd be slimmer but still stocky I'd
like to be more confident in myself and
be more tech-savvy oh is that so he
turned him on straight way through the
door of the ominous music you say yes
[Music]
where you going he did pretty great I'm
[Music]
Haitian
Marquis Moo Bowie Pierrot the target
physical appearance must extract beauty
from confidence within huh
characteristic synopsis is a patient
cancer curious about their environment
their curiosity makes them hyper aware
yeah you decide to look at a lot of
things orders know they made their own
decisions no matter the risk patient
reaction when faced with danger they
showed promising sizes of three cuz you
went straight for the monster I'm very
impressed patient remains imperfect oh
yeah what always cuz there's no such
thing I'm sorry mark you should make me
perfect yeah but you didn't read the TV
in the lab room that showed you that
most of the time it doesn't break and
you can't take off the headset once
you've got a
sorry no don't close the game wait I
gotta go back make me perfect are you
actually gonna play it again no way you
ought to be perfect right we all want to
be perfect I can't live with my
disgusting self I think there is like a
deeper message in this book there is
okay my name is Mark Fischbach Fishbach
that's me I am man okay all right I'm
gonna do exactly as you say I'm gonna do
exactly as you say and I ain't gonna do
nothing wrong
this is interesting like make mark I'm
still developing so maybe I should you
are not smiling no cuz that would points
that you can never be perfect but maybe
I should put something I'll make
something happen if you do follow all
the orders oh you're not you're not
smiling either which one does he choose
oh did he choose the little man on his
own this time oh [ __ ] I see something I
see nothing it's the same thing that
happens you said you were gonna follow
orders this time max I don't know you
know some new it'd be nice you lie
my head my back my [ __ ] in my crack
okay that's right I sing that I'm a
ukulele
okay I'm not happy with you man no I am
so frickin happy with you look at them
look at them look at them look at them
for longer perfect just the way you are
that's the moral of the story you're all
perfect just the way you are mark gets
it though hmm you just get it oh you're
gone yeah we left you alone because
you're supposed to be afraid of being
ill I know the same things happen the
canvas is blank what happened okay all
right hello oh [ __ ] okay I'm out of here
I guess he still don't find the Easter
egg right okay if you say so
bye hello coming for you won't you go to
Gucci you got run away okay fear of
being alone endorse dopamine receptors
without needing for external stimulants
curiosity makes them hyper where they
made their own decisions promise the
sides of bravery patient remains
imperfect we'll restart it you can't
did you try again I feel so bad the
goodest boy there's definitely more that
I need to do on this game oh my god go
straight to the end of the tunnel I'll
be fine here we go okay
there we go okay where's my notebook
should I be taking this why don't you
try being in my room no other
distractions Boop okay alright I'm a
curious little baby okay baby that's
that's not right that's not right
I do like the eyes I think the eyes are
my favorite he said she said good we
actually find one that kind of freaks
them out you should change this to the
side you still haven't looked at the TV
that explains to you the headset but
it's fine it's fine
Ola mom he might be the perfect like a
perfect baby perfect baby we're watching
you anything anything especially you
guys are not gonna be not here baby
okay what are you gonna do now well
screw that [ __ ] oh I'm not sure really
nervous I'm like well I'm nothing
changes okay yeah there's a little tiny
glitch there but you can't go through
cuz it's got Collider on it okay
whatever that's not okay can I go back
now go back that's fine I don't care
I don't care I'm just gonna go argue
okay hopefully it will say that you were
doing okay all right fear of judgement
self-worth must be enlarged and not
reliant
other attributes prove somewhat curious
but remain focused yes they will obey
over taking a risk yeah you're fearful
[Applause]
and he's my contract uncle had that
changed yo-yo your your is there any
other is there any other thing to do
about this I guess at the end of the day
the only thing you can do is run and
perfect oh well yeah I guess we have to
just accept the flaws that we have
inside of our souls because really the
beauty is only skin-deep they say but in
truth the perception of the beauty is
much deeper than maybe this guy's the
inner workings of our own mind and
accept our own perfections because we
are perfect in just the way we are
without needing any sort of false
gratification for our own perfect
systems mm-hmm the image of ourselves
that we look in the mirror the one
person that we are that's what we have
to accept at the end of the day I know
what I'm talking about here you're
making perfection I think we all learned
something today perfection lies in here
not in here in here not in here in here
not in here I think what I'm talking
about there thank you everybody so much
for watching do you want to be perfect
for yourself I'll leave a link to the
game in the description below
oh so much for watching and as always
I'll see you in the next Arace famous
terra is famous
Terry's famous Terra's famous I love
Tara that's terrible the way that that
dude I have like oh I loved her that
concept at this monster like four or
five years ago now and now is 3d model
and now he's famous and I'm excited
well run Tara well done Terra um and
thank you Mike okay should we should we
write a lovely big comment to mark
to say thank you blip blip that's true
jacks and Joker's like you have a video
that's the notes my ire so I'm so
old-school
yes oh okay right so I've got a I've got
a just okay so let's write a comment can
you guys see what I'm writing you can't
if I put it up a bit more yeah okay so I
mean why I got it's obvious why I got so
excited but why I I don't know just like
it's absolutely unreal to know that you
spent nearly a year making a game and
thinking it's just like overthinking it
and not think it was good enough or
whatever and then not only people play
it but that people like freaking
markiplier players like absolutely
absolutely crazy because I made it in
university and you know there were times
when our lecturers did not understand it
there's no like um there's no action
mechanics there's no way to like kill
the monster or anything like that and I
wanted it to be more about atmosphere I
wanted and they wanted it I wanted it to
be again that made you think I wanted it
to be a game that made you kind of
analyze yourself and that's what
markiplier I was doing so I was very
very happy about that
thank you so much for the jump outside
man I really really really appreciate
that really appreciate that
any little helps and if I'm gonna carry
on developing this game or more games in
the future every little helps my
congratulations on a job well done yaks
like he said could have done with
another ending but it was very good to
watch especially with mark playing it
thank you thank you thank you ever
really really appreciate that do let me
know if you want me to carry on
developing the game or have you seen too
much and you once [ __ ] phone and you
want me to start on another project
absolutely crazy especially because of
this game as well because like Mark said
like he got it he hit the nail on the
head some people thought that I was
calling myself the perfect one because
in the video at the start or you know
just like taunting then and I guess I
kind of am in a way but the the main
thing is that at times we do just crave
perfection so so so much we just wish we
can be perfect we wish we could you know
I don't know if you want to play guitar
if you want to be a chef like whatever
you want to do if you want to be a
youtuber you just kick yourself
constantly because you're not you're not
as good as this person even though
you're better than that person and it's
not even a facts of are you better than
them or are you getting more views in
them or are you getting more money than
them it's all about the way that you
view yourself and how how happy you are
at the end of the day because literally
nobody is perfect and even if you get to
a standard that you believe is perfect
bet you you're gonna talk to someone
else show someone else whatever you
think is perfect in it's not gonna be
perfect in their eyes so there is no
point in striving for that and then yeah
I just claim it ah thank you so much
Michael really really appreciate that
two pounds most people like the glitz
eating photos by the way they like the
glitching photos they thought it was yes
it's not a bug it's a feature it's not a
bug it's a feature but yes yeah there's
this idea just sent from like already
late night where I was like how can I be
perfect maybe if I stop cross netting
maybe if I stop watching YouTube videos
or maybe if I stop reading books and
like playing games and all the stuff
that I enjoy doing I can just knuckle
down a be perfect but you know what if
you got rid of all of that stuff then
you wouldn't be you you would be like
just a shell you would be a robot and
that's not fun this there's no fun so
yeah anyway thank you so much Michael I
use can't believe it let's find a
comment to market flex okay um thanks
minivans thank you everyone thank you
everyone thanks James thanks
absolutely everyone thanks someone and
thanks Oh J gaming um uh and a thousand
one speedster as well so I don't think
harshly critical played it
so that's right that's right a comment
oh I don't even know where to start
thank you
probably it's a good start thank you
[Music]
thank you so much for playing for
playing for playing this is difficult I
am the game designer dev and go in the
video and thought in the video and oh I
don't even know what to say I'm ready to
update your comment thanks yeah this is
just too much this is just two minutes
right okay right so um thank you so much
playing on the game designer slash step
and girl in the video what do I say now
um and it means so much to me that you
took the time to to play some something
wait wait my comic I'm guessing my
comment is still up there yeah okay that
means so much to me and took so much
time to create you
ah-ha you perfectly got across the
meaning within the game you perfectly
got the meaning because it was awesome
to see your reactions and I've taken hot
pot the glitch some glitches so thanks
again you perfectly got the meeting got
across the meeting within the game ok I
think I think that's a good comment yeah
what you think yeah yeah I chatted too
harshly critical a couple times like a
couple years ago I don't think he has
played it you know I don't think so what
a bad present joking he doesn't no one
else a player and I think if you played
it once you don't need to pay again know
if you've seen it once you don't you
already each player huh thank you so
much scarf for coming and checking out
the channel after watching the game
just put eight smile just a smile just
keep it single simple don't mention the
glitches okay okay okay fine go bye
okay
I wanted to know oh wait I already said
it way that you took the time to play
something that oh I'm an over thinking
of absolutely everything I'm the game
video and it means so much for you to
time to play this balls just come on
stupid this it was awesome see your
reactions you perfectly got me because
yeah whatever cool perfection Battle
Royale
oh yeah because everything is better
well males do in those days nowadays
okay sent I still can't believe it
this is absolutely mental this is great
this is great all the hard work it's
just paying off and I just can't can't
be happier cannot be happier my nose
ring brings it down to a 9bh this ain't
going away I love this ah wait so who is
the guy because those people pictures
are apparently of real-life people and
that's a bit creepy good I'm glad
I'm glad that the real-life pictures
made you feel uneasy that was the whole
point
yeah so I'm glad I am glad
ah okay oh okay
I'm fine too like the Adrenaline's going
down now so oh my gosh just yes bloody
how what the hell so crazy so crazy so
crazy ha okay one sec one sec I'll touch
you in the comments for a little bit
then I'll go actually you know um Mark
said I don't know I put these back on
I'm not listening to anything you know
Mark said that he know you know Mark was
like my neck my back don't wanna sing
that for you before well I'm still here
because I haven't seen that in a long
time and it would be fun
I like to come in thanks Becca me what's
going on here go me you just missed it
Mike a player played perfection and
that's the game that I that I developed
with my uni my uni team Tiffani and
Tabitha yeah yeah yeah it's yeah someone
a prototype you posted it yes I have
Jackson Jack and no I am not perfect
ghost King because nobody's perfect
nobody's perfect gosh I just can't
believe this is absolutely crazy like
you still it's you wanna I don't know
just you want to cut all my old
housemates but they're not here so it's
pretty sad but it would be nice if they
were um okay what am I saying
Oh
TIF and tabs Dell Wyse Selene I will
keep this up for a little bit I might
actually upload like an actual video of
it it's so weird bigger youtuber and
then seeing the opposite side of it so
like saying no stop it I don't let you
play new Canadian ones I've been so busy
I've been lecturing guys how weird is
that I'm not sure okay okay I yelled
Hades if you feel like this may be party
time stop Thomas are you ladies if you
feeling like this if your body don't
stop to miss just the way the way do it
do it right now do it
like that just like you should right now
do I count like that just like you shirt
my neck my back connect my [ __ ] and my
crack my neck my back my [ __ ]
[Music]
the main D monetized ah yeah actually I
always start all of my overnight nights
because it just it just gets them
interested I guess and what they're
about to listen to this year boy okay
I'll pay one more song and then I'll go
I'm still just so what the hell I need
singing upbeat one okay it's nearly nine
o'clock I still need to do some work cuz
I've got a lecture to deliver tomorrow
and I was supposed to be doing it
tonight but this happened so you know
[Music]
I've got to I've got a hair in my mouth
sometimes I feel I've got to run away
I've got to get away from the pin you
travel to the heart of me love for sure
in secure nowhere and have lost my life
but I've tossed until I can't sleep I
once I ran to you now I run from you
this Tainted Love you've given I give
you all a girl can't give you take my
tears and that's not nearly all
[Music]
now I know I've got to run away I've got
to get away it's a really wanna tease
out from me to make things right you
need someone to hold you tight and you
think love is to play baby I'm sorry I
don't play that away once I ran to you
now I run from you this Tainted Love
you've given I give you all a girl can't
give you take my tears and that's
don't touch me I can't stand the way you
tease me baby okay thank you very much
for coming hello and welcome to anybody
that is new as well as developing games
I also play them I upload here I sing
songs I talk about games and I love
horror so that's my thing that's why I
made the horror games so yeah makes
sense right okay so if you want to stick
around subscribe do all the good stuff
and hopefully I'll see you around yeah
thank you thanks again just so much to
everyone for all your support always
brought throughout the game development
always support throughout my youtube
everything just absolutely everything
thank you thank you so much if you want
to play the game and you haven't yet
then you can find it on it but I'll just
quickly link it to you now and the best
way to keep in contact with me is either
through my Instagram I'm on there are
lots or my Twitter so that's my Twitter
and my Instagram is basically the same
but with Instagram I'm same
YAG my necks on everything you could
find me absolutely everywhere so anyway
thank you so much for all the
congratulations I really really really
really really appreciate it really
appreciate it
I'll keep this up for a little bit I
have recorded it on an actual camera as
well so who knows I might make a more
professional video out of this but yeah
you can watch it back if you want to I
I won't be deleting it straightaway so
if you missed it and you want to see me
cringing or me just getting super
excited which I still am but yeah you
can go back and check all that out so
yeah anyway
Friday the 13th will be free on ps4 this
month ok I need to get back onto the
PlayStation PlayStation Plus members
right I I'm not on that anymore but I
need I need to get back on there so I
can get all the free games and stuff so
let me say goodbye to who I can see in
the chat so I can actually say goodbye
to you guys hey Tom sorry
I'm going bye tom but you can still
check out the video you can go back ok
goodbye
someone good bye 1001 speedster goodbye
Jack and Jack goodbye Aziz gamer goodbye
run to to zest to to to 7 thirst how
long did it take to make the game just
under a year from conceptualizing to the
end where it is now and I'm still trying
to develop it like every spare moment
that I have Jackson Jack goodbye
disturbia oh sorry
welcome to survey you can still watch it
just go back and the comments are live
you can see them on the side I love that
by the way it's made it's so much better
but yeah thank you for coming
but sorry goodbye goodbye Jesse could by
Michael goodbye Elena
goodbye Becca me goodbye man's house
goodbye the Chihuahua goodbye I ate my
elbow what a great name oh my gosh thank
you so much pay on and think you think
you think you champagne on me well boy
and I just take you off for that old
girl sorry to assume your gender or and
be um be gender Asst gender fluid that's
the one and B gender is that word that
could be a word am b and b gendered that
makes sense right anyway
goodbye Jesse goodbye ghost King bye
Tiffany thank you for coming TIFF TIFF
can you freakin believe it TIFF is the
environment designer by the way can you
believe it if you love markiplier - yes
you do love my Clyde on you but yeah
anyway so device car good bye J talk
and thank you I will keep doing because
I enjoy it and that's that's amazing
goodbye James you can call me Joker
goodbye Joe can have a little read day
or evening and good bye to everyone
who's lurking in the chat that might not
be accessible to the chat so liking in
the video looks let's move to the chat
goodbye have a lovely day or evening
yeah see you later